et l'autre entité politique ce matin
c'est gilles platret bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous à chalon sur
saône vice président des républicains on
va bien sûr parler des législatives et
votre parti mais d'abord une première
question puisque emmanuel macron est
actuellement en route pour kiev avec
olaf scholz le chancelier allemand et
mario draghi le chef du gouvernement
italien c'est une bonne chose qu'ils se
rendent à kiev c'est la première fois
depuis le début de la guerre oui je
pense que le président est dans son rôle
pour le coup s'il m'arrive d'être sévère
avec sa politique intérieure je pense
que sur le plan international
il représente quelque part ce que nous
souhaitons c'est à dire une position
d'équilibré qui ne soit pas
aveuglément atlantiste puisqu'on sait
très bien que les etats unis ont aussi
les intérêts propres à défendre dans
cette affaire et que finalement en
important message sur place qui est très
important au nom de l'europe qui dont il
présidait les destinées jusqu'au 30 juin
et en disant finalement pas de
précipitation il n'y a pas d'
intégration immédiate de l'ukraine par
exemple dans le bloc européen bien sûr
qu'il appartient historiquement mais on
peut regarder sur les institutions et
prendre notre temps je pense qu'il est
dans une position d'équilibré tout cas
moi qui me convient bien il n'y a pas de
précipitation il n'y a pas de suivisme
mais par contre y ait une solidarité et
il ya aussi un dialogue qui doit être
maintenu avec la russie ça ça me paraît
très important nous ne sommes pas
c'est une nécessité quand on regarde
l'histoire unis et la russie mais ce
serait une folie pour toute l'europe
occidentale ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est un blanc seing donné à monsieur
poutine dans ses volontés annexionnistes
qui sont manifestes par la force par la
violence ça nous le condamnons je pense
que on a quand même montré un degré de
réprobation qui est assez digne de ce
que nous sommes et des valeurs que nous
défendons pour autant continuer le
dialogue ça me paraît absolument
essentiel même dans les pires conditions
parce que le jour n'est plus dialogue
effectivement on est sur une logique
d'isolationnisme complet aux dépens de
la russie et c'est une très mauvaise
chose pour l'europe toute entière
et fisc avant de partir roumanie en
moldavie et en ukraine emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport il appelait les français lui
donner une majorité solide est-ce que
vous qui êtes bolis vous dites mais oui
c'est important pour la stabilité du
pays le président de la république
dispose d'une majorité solide pour
gouverner moi je pense que c'est
important pour la démocratie que la
liberté reviennent à l'assemblée
nationale qu'il a une majorité relative
je pense que ça serait pas de majorité
il nous faut une majorité de toute façon
il y aura je ne crois pas une seule
seconde pour parler clairement que
monsieur mélenchon puisse disposer d'une
quelconque majorité à l'issue des
élections dimanche prochain c'est très
clair ça a été agitée par là le blog
présidentielle avant le premier tour
pour ramener très clair pour ramener des
voix de droite sur le bloc mas-grenier
en disant attention l'homme au couteau
entre les dents jean luc mélenchon
s'avance de ces pouvoir sanguinaire
jusqu'à la semaine nationale tremblay
bonnes gens voter pour nous ça a plutôt
bien fonctionné un certain nombre de
circonscriptions je pourrais vous en
parlait à titre personnel compris dans
la batterie compris dans la vie elle
même et bien sûr mais personne
aujourd'hui aucun l'analyse politique ne
vous dis monsieur mélenchon sera
majoritaire pour une simple et bonne
raison il n'a pas de réserve de voix
pour le deuxième tour donc il aura un
bon groupe c'est une évidence mais bien
sûr qu'il sera pas majoritaires donc il
reste deux solutions ou bien monsieur
macron a réussi son coup de force quand
je défends respect de l'institution mais
c'est à dire un coup de force
psychologique en disant vous avez peur
donc voter pour les candidats mais dans
ce cas là il est en majorité absolue
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce cas là
mais va se passer en fait la même chose
qu'il ya cinq ans c'est à dire une
assemblée nationale sous contrôle où le
débat est complètement contingenter ou
le contrôle du gouvernement est réduit
qui se souvient encore qu'au début de la
précédente législature
il y avait deux jours de questions au
gouvernement pour contrôler l'action du
gouvernement eh bien depuis vous
n'arrivez plus qu'un vous êtes réduits à
deux minutes et oncle en clair le
contrôle s'est réduit comme peau de
chagrin sera allongé un oui mais enfin
attendez sauf que on sait bien que les
conditions du contrôle n'ont pas été là
si le sénat n'avait pas été ici sur la
sphère benalla qu'il aurait contrôlé à
l'assemblée nationale donc on voit bien
que on a besoin d'une assemblée qui
respire et s'il ya une majorité relative
deuxième cas de figure je pense que
c'est quand même ce surcoût envers ans
on se dessine et ça me semble se
dessiner en tout cas sur le terrain
ça veut dire concrètement quoi ça veut
dire que les oppositions toutes les
oppositions retrouve du pouvoir le
pouvoir de discuter la loi le pouvoir
d'être respecté par la majorité relative
bien sûr que le premier ministre ou la
première ministre sera issu du bloc le
plus important donc le bloc macro niamey
il devra où elle devra discuter pied à
pied chaque loi sans mépriser ces
oppositions et ça ça s'appelle le retour
du jeu parlementaire je pense que dans
l'état de notre démocratie
avec une abstention record comme on l'a
jamais vue jusqu'à présent c'est
vraiment un record historique redonner
de l'air aux députés redonner de l'air
au débat démocratique à l'assemblée
c'est une très bonne chose pour le long
terme donc c'est vraiment ce à quoi il
faut à un moment donné s'attendre en
tout cas je pense que ça se dessine mais
c'est surtout une espérance pour l'adsl
et c'est l'incapacité d'empêcher
emmanuel macron d'obtenir une majorité
absolue ce ne sont pas les candidats de
la nuit parce que dans ces cas là c'est
pas aussi jouer contre votre camp
est ce que vous n'avez pas ignorer le
fait que ans nous avons plusieurs
dizaines de candidats qui sont en lice
et que nous avons bon espoir dimanche
soir de nous conter avec un groupe
significatif à l'assemblée nationale je
pense que en étant raisonnable toujours
difficile et pronostiques parce que il
vous revient dans la figure si jamais
vous êtes trompés mais en étant
raisonnable je pense que nous aurons une
soixantaine de députés les républicains
qui constitueront un groupe alors c'est
moins que la dernière fois c'est une
évidence mais c'est beaucoup plus que ce
qu'on nous promettait en disant rappelez
vous vous allez disparaître de
l'échiquier d'ailleurs avant les
élections vous allez tous vous rallié au
camp présidentiel ça ne s'est pas passé
à quelques exceptions près et donc nos
députés sont restés fidèles je pense ce
sera essentiellement des députés
sortants qui seront reconduits il y aura
quelques nouvelles têtes est tant mieux
à l'assemblée nationale mais en tout cas
on peut raisonnablement tabler sur un
groupe de soixante donc ça veut dire un
groupe qui existe
qui fera son boulot
mais est ce que vous serez une force
d'appoint
nature est ce que vous serez dans une
opposition radicale vous savez alors je
pense que la vérité est entre les deux
quand vous êtes un député responsable
some good hit je suis là pour tout
bloquer bravo aux cinq ans a tout bloqué
belle perspective professionnelle enfin
jure que c'est l'antithèse de ce que
doit être le député le député est là
pour contrôler gouvernement et examiner
les projets de loi à apporter des
amendements améliorer les textes de loi
si vous mettez dans la tête dès le
départ que de toute façon vous ne
voterez rien comment voulez vous amener
quelque chose de positif au débat
parlementaire les députés républicains
resteront dans l'opposition ça a été dit
et redit nous l'avons exprimée
clairement nous n'allons pas être une
force d'appoint pour consolider une
majorité relative du président de macron
car s'est exprimé clairement par la
majorité il ya quand même certaines
personnes cello suis dit il faut qu'on
passe un pacte de gouvernement avec le
gps elles ces personnes sont ultra
minoritaires et je les respecte je pense
que ça n'est pas la bonne chose est du
reste on a un peu trancher tout ça
encore une fois rappelez-vous les appels
de certains juste après la
présidentielle en disant rejoignons le
camp de monsieur macro ça n'a pas
fonctionné puisque encore une fois à
quelques exceptions près personne
quasiment personne n'a rejoint le camp
présidentiel donc ce n'est pas n'importe
qui il y avait par exemple nicolas
sarkozy lui qui a appelé sur un pacte de
gouvernement on l'a vu au premier tour
des législatives il a soutenu la
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
dans les alpes maritimes face à une
candidate d'eric ciotti là au second
tour il a reçu une candidate de la
majorité présidentielle alors que dans
la même circonscription il ya une
candidate a l'air est ce que vous dites
il n'a plus sa place une où est-ce qu'il
a encore sa place au républicain nicolas
sarkozy avec une tâche immense qui l'a
pas une place aux républicains il a une
place dans l'histoire il a été président
pendant que les républicains non mais
alors je vais vous dire si vous me
demander d'approuver ce qui est en train
de se passer certainement pas voilà je
veux redire ici mon total soutien à
brigitte kuster en particulier qui a été
bien chamboulé par une visite qui a été
fait rue de miromesnil par son opposante
auprès nicolas sarkozy ya quelques jours
je pense qu'il ne fallait pas recevoir
sept personnes qui sont très honorables
et quand on a quelqu'un qui vous a été
fidèle depuis toujours on ne fait pas ce
coup là à trois jours du deuxième tour
dans une position qu'elle a à consolider
et qui est encore fragile même si je
suis certain qu'elle va renverser la
situation mais il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique exclamé je suis même
pas sûr je veux vous dire très
honnêtement pour l'exclure il faudrait
qu'il ait renouvelé sa cotisation je
suis pas sûr que ça soit le cas voilà je
demandais aux trésoriers c'est lui qui
les financent donc ya pas besoin d'être
une école sarkozy je pense que de toute
façon enfin il s'est souvenu mais il est
il est déjà plus membre des républicains
un jeu mais encore une fois je le dis
avec un infini respect pour ce qu'il a
fait mais je pense que là il renouveler
mais lille ne joue pas sa meilleure
partition très honnêtement il y a
tout le monde et tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord chez vous vous l'avez dit sur
l'attitude à adopter est ce qu'à un
moment il va falloir se poser et revoir
la ligne de votre parti et sur quelle
ligne est ce qu'il faut aller sur une
ligne plutôt tourné vers le centre où
est ce qu'il faut aller sur une minime
de droite affirmé ça va être le travail
des mois qui viennent on avait dit on
attend les législatives pour entamer ce
travail là les législatives seront
terminés dimanche soir si la droite
républicaine ne se met pas
en condition de faire le bilan de ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui dans l'opinion
si elle ne se met pas en condition de le
tirer finalement la somme de tout ce
qu'elle a fait depuis vingt ans de tout
ce qui a fonctionné et ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné en clair si elle ne redéfinit
pas un corps de doctrine cohérent alors
elle disparaîtra on aura notre groupe
qui fera son boulot à l'assemblée mais
il y aura aucune perspective est en tout
cas aucune perspective à 5 ans pour la
prochaine prochaine présidentielle vous
poser la vraie question je vais pas
apporté j'ai un sentiment évidemment une
conviction sur la réponse on peut pas
être en même temps centriste et de
droite faut être très clair là dessus et
ceux qui le pensent pas dans la foulée
de la création de l'ump voyez je remonte
très loin ont sans doute eu raison sur
le court terme ce que ça nous a permis
de gagner des élections mais on voit
bien sur le long terme ça n'est plus
audible donc l'alliance de la droite et
du centre ça doit être fini pour moi je
ne pense qu'il doit y avoir une alliance
mais justement l'alliance est pas dans
la même maison vous pouvez voir une
alliance électorale t on a quand même
des partis qui sont capable de s'allier
regarder du ps aujourd'hui et pourtant
c'est des alliances qui souvent sont
contre électorale ait l'air ça doit plus
être les partis de la droite et du
centre je pense que c'est une ça serait
une erreur de le considérer comme tel
parce que si ça a fonctionné au moment
de la création de l'ump ça nous a mis
dans la même maison et et finalement ça
nous a amené quelques victoires on voit
bien aujourd'hui que ce paradigme
étaient soufflées et que nous devons
nous repensé dans une ligne idéologique
beaucoup plus clair n est plus lisible
sinon nous aurions fait un bien meilleur
score à l'élection présidentielle bien
sûr on peut mettre ça sur le dos de
valérie pécresse je n'ai pas été son
soutien comme vous le savez dans cette
élection j'ai estimé que l elle nous
emmener à la catastrophe je n'avais pas
pensé que c'était à ce point là en tout
cas je n'ai pas soutenu je suis resté
sur ma réserve et je n'ai gêner personne
pour autant ça n'est pas que le fait de
valérie pécresse qui s'est passé quand
vous avez 95 % des français qui ne vous
écoutent plus c'est que vous avez un
problème
d'audition au sens littéral du terme
c'est à dire on ne vous entend plus
notre travail est premier et ça a
commencé vous savez comment vous avez
des groupes qui commence à réfléchir
alors peut-être l'écart différentes ont
de petites chapelles je pense que ce
débat doit se passer à l'intérieur de l
air mais s'ils nous n'avons pas ce
courage d'aller jusqu'au fond des choses
de faire un vrai inventaire et de tracer
une ligne pour demain jamais nous ne
reviendrons au pouvoir national c'est
aussi simple que ça les français
attendent de nous de la clarté c'est à
nous de faire ce travail mais est-ce que
vous avez encore une place dans la
recomposition du paysage politique est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas vos
électeurs qui sont parties d'un côté
chez emmanuel macron ce du centre et de
l'autre vers marine le pen est
aujourd'hui votre place ou ericsson pour
deux ans et aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
place pour les élèves le résultat
d'élections législatives dans votre
circonscription
vous êtes arrivé troisième est ce que ce
n'est pas une illustration de 5
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de place pour
les républicains je pense que non parce
que je vais vous dire pourquoi sur le
sur le constat immédiat ou pouvait dire
effectivement vous êtes en train de
disparaître
mais je suis sauriens de formation et
les idées ont la vie dure c'est pas
parce que vous subissez une série de
revers que vous êtes appelés à
disparaître si vous ne fait pas ce qu'il
faut effectivement disparaîtra si on
comme si on ne recule arifi plus notre
position notre doctrine est logique
c'est enfin je vous fiche mon billet
qu'effectivement nous disparaîtrons mais
je pense très honnêtement qu'il ya dans
ce pays place pour une droite
républicaine qui soit forte sur le
régalien on ne vous nous dites à juste
titre vous avez une partie de nos
électeurs qui sont partis chez chez
monsieur macron c'est sans doute
d'ailleurs ce qui m'a coûté ma
qualification au deuxième tour dans ma
circonscription pas faire un cas
particulier est certain que c'est un cas
comme beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs
puisque ça s'est passé il ya un
transfert bien la cité par la peur de
l'homme au couteau entre les dents
monsieur mélenchon qui a fait peur une
partie des électeurs qui sont parties
d'un côté moi j'ai une bascule de 500
électeurs qui me coûte la qualification
au deuxième tour pour autant je ne suis
pas certain que ses électeurs quand vous
les interrogez sur le bilan sécuritaire
de macron le bilan migratoire de
monsieur macron la lutte contre le
communautarisme soient satisfaits de
l'action du président de la république
donc ça veut dire concrètement que sur
ces sujets régaliens là nous avons
quelque chose à dire pas dans les
outrances de madame le pen qui a
toujours gros si le problème qui a parlé
dans tous les sens de ces sujets et
finalement n'apporte rien nous avons en
la matière a dit marine le pen elle a
redit sur france 2 cette semaine a dit
mais si on n'a pas nous un groupe
puissant l'assemblée nationale
l'immigration le communautarisme la
question de l'islam on en parlera plus à
l'assemblée nationale écoutez je pense
que les français veulent en parler alors
là pour le coup je peux vous le dire
comme maire et comme candidat aux
législatives parce que c'est ce que j'ai
à dire que vous n'êtes pas même d'en
parler pour elle c'est ça le message non
je pense que nous avons aujourd'hui
quelque chose à défendre qu'ils soient
de l'ordre du raisonnable c'est à dire
de la fermeté régaliennes sans doute
ranger extrême pas jamais on ne fera
dire que le débat démocratique doit être
confiée aux extrêmes je pense que c'est
une façon de le diluer parce qu'en
réalité on voit très bien madame le pen
a tout fait je vais peut-être un peu
iconoclaste a tout fait pour ne pas
gagner cette élection elle est là elle a
fait tourner sa boutique elle fait
tourner sa boutique mais elle ne veut
pas gagner pour moi mais je vous donne
un exemple très clair autant autant
illustré débats du deuxième tour d'entre
deux tours madame le pen et mais les
équipes de monsieur macro mais madame le
pen négocient les conditions du débat à
quelle heure arrive les sujets sur la
sécurité ou madame le pen a un avantage
comparatif par rapport à monsieur macron
à 23 heures madame le pen a tout fait
pour ne pas gagner cette élection quand
on aura compris quand les électeurs
auront compris que le clan le pen quand
le clan le pen ce que monsieur bardella
c'est le petit fils donc on a on a c'est
un clan familial que ce clan est là pour
faire tourner sa boutique qu'il n'a rien
à faire de gagner l'élection qu'il veut
juste avoir des voix pour faire tourner
un parti politique alors peut-être qu'on
aura intérêt à se tourner vers d'autres
parties qui eux ont une culture de
gouvernement et qui veulent changer les
choses moi je suis convaincu et je ne
cesserai de le dire que madame le pen
est une tromperie pour le peuple
français non seulement parce qu'elle est
démago et ça on le sait mais surtout
parce qu'elle ne veut pas gagner vous
avez bien vu la campagne des élections
de ça dit il se réveille à trois jours
du premier tour mais c'est une dès le
départ bardella nous dit monsieur par me
dit pas son nom mais on on sera pas
majoritaire à l'assemblée c'est le
premier message de rassemblement
pourquoi parce qu'ils ne veulent sur
elle même les nommer mais bien sûr ils
l'ont dit parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
gagner ils veulent faire tourner une
boutique familiale qui fonctionne bien
depuis 60 ans reconnaissons que quand
même c'est un objet ludique et
intéressant rassemblement national
depuis 60 ans cette boutique familiale
tourner et pour autant ça n'est pas la
solution pour les français et ça ça fera
aussi partie du boulot qu'on devra avoir
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique
vis-à-vis des électeurs si on veut
demain reconquérir ce qu'on a perdu
notamment parce que la dilution de nos
idées de droite
dans un magma qui était pas simplement
de droite qui était centré droit nous a
perdu des électeurs donc retrouvons le
chemin du régalien nous sommes le parti
gaulliste que nous sommes le parti
fondateur la vème république nous sommes
le parti patriote par excellence celui
qui a sauvé la france du désastre à
plusieurs reprises pendant la guerre est
également 58 donc retrouvons ce chemin
là je pense qu'il ya une voie pour nous
reconstruire sur cette base là notamment
et pour ça il va falloir un chef j'ai le
plâtre et qui pour succéder à christian
jacob pendant il faut une personnalité
me semble-t-il qui ne soit pas déjà
embarqué dans l'aventuré qui va se
passer dans cinq ans si on devait
retomber dans un jeu d'écurie je vois
bien les choses commençaient à se
redessiner chez nous
certains se sentant sans doute à juste
titre à dessein présidentiel et ce qui
ne l'est pas de mettre des noms lassus
chacun se reconnaîtra et d'ailleurs il y
en a un certain nombre mais si chacun
reconstituer des écuries en prévision de
c'est fini on va disparaître moi je
plaide pour une présidence qui soit une
présidence un peu temporaire c'est à
dire le ton de la sélection de notre
candidat pour 2027 n'est pas encore
arrivé il faudra que ces serres de
christian jacob ne doit pas être le
candidat à la présidence en des jeux
alors là on a fait une erreur
fondamentale la dernière fois quand on
quand on a choisi un successeur à
laurent wauquiez on a imposé une règle
d'ailleurs c'était le prison de l'arche
et le premier qu'il avait imposé cette
règle tous les candidats devront prendre
l'engagement de ne pas être candidat ils
sont présents ciel moi je ne veux plus
de cette règle pas ce que ça veut dire
que vous avez un président qui renoncent
par avance à toute ambition non je pense
qu'ils font un profil qui rassemble qui
nous fasse travailler un profil qui qui
a envie de faire bouger sur les lignes
idéologiques qui veulent que cette
maison travaille sur sa doctrine
mais qui ne soit pas forcément je dis
bien forcément celui qui a déjà
l'ambition de nous conduire à la
bataille en 2027 dans les chats alors
invoqué je n'ai pas à ce stade oui parce
que vous pensez qu'il est candidat pour
2027 intel pour ses fautes mais qu'il a
des ambitions il n'aime pas les seuls
vous savez très bien parce que tout le
monde aujourd'hui
regarde la ligne bleue des vosges 2027
en pensant que ça peut être son tour je
dis simplement que si cette machine là
se mettait en route maintenant on
donnerait un spectacle absolument
détestable mais tu étais sable à
l'opinion publique et jamais on ne
remontera la pente donc déjà du boulot
du boulot intellectuelle du boulot de
doctrine qu'est ce que nous sommes
qu'est ce que nous voulons pour le pays
est-ce qu'on peut clarifier notre ligne
meilleur coût parce que par exemple
bruno retailleau il a écrit un livre de
plusieurs centaines de pages pour
refonder sur le fond votre parti est ce
que lui puisque nous avons je suis pas
je vais pas ce soir ce matin vous dire
c'est pas enregistrer un jeu direct je
ne vais pas vous dire je sais intel plus
qu'un autre mais il nous faut un profil
qui nous fasse bosser mais sur celle sur
le fond sur la ligne de bruno retailleau
de laurent wauquiez sur une ligne de
droite voilà c'est très clair sont venus
à bout quel rôle comptez vous jouer
j'espère que j'agis traits un peu le
cocotier aussi plutôt ma nature je pense
j'ai commencé à travailler vous savez il
ya du travail public et il ya du travail
en équipe qui se voit pas forcément
commencer à avoir un quotidien un groupe
autour de moi deux personnes qui sont
venues me donner un coup de main pour
pouvoir travailler sur le fond de la
doctrine c'est pas forcément ce qui
briguera le plus dans un premier temps
mais ce travail est nécessaire donc je
vais continuer là-dessus on verra après
la position au moment j'ai évidemment
envie de m'investir à quelle place ça on
le verra le moment venu mais ce que vous
êtes candidat pour succéder à christian
jalby passage je ne dis pas ça ce matin
chez vous je n'exclus rien non plus
c'est sûr surtout pas en train de faire
une déclaration de candidature devant
vous parce que je pense qu' il peut y
avoir des configurations qui nous
rassemble encore une fois je préférerais
on se rassemble plutôt qu'on se divisent
mais en tout état de cause je le dis
très clairement et je vous le dis en
sincérité je compte évidemment
m'appliquer beaucoup dans la
reconstruction de cette famille
politique et au delà de la famille de
cette philosophie politique parce que
c'est ça à mon sens dont la france a
besoin à un dernier mot sur une autre
actualité scène révélations de mediapart
mediapart qui a recueilli le témoignage
d'une élue centriste qui dit avoir été
victime d'une tentative de viol en 2010
de la part de damien abad damien abad
qui était le président de groupe ndlr
jusqu'il ya peu et des abbés de bornes
emmanuel macron ont-ils raison de la
maintenir au gouvernement ça devient un
vrai problème politique voilà moi je
suis alors je vais je suis très
embarrassé dans cette affaire pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il ya le ressentiment
d'un homme qui nous a trahis et qui
pourraient j'allais dire nous dicter une
conduite d' extrême sévérité vis-à-vis
de lui mais j'essaye de m'extirper de ça
parce que c'était vraiment une trahison
j'étais le premier d'ailleurs a demandé
il ya bien des semaines qu'il quitte la
présidence du groupe n'avait pas été
cité à l'époque je pense qu'on aurait
clarifié les choses avant que bon mais
oublions ça je suis partagé parce que il
ya des il ya une présomption d'innocence
est un principe républicain si vous la
jetée aux orties alors demain vous moi
tout le monde peut être accusé et dans
ce cas là on brise des vies sans avoir
de fondement établi par la justice mais
je pense qu'on a un vrai problème
politique et j'avais dit lors des
premières révélations que si il y en
avait d'autres la situation deviendrait
compliqué bon donc j'ai cru comprendre
que l'avocate de cette plaignante est en
train de rassembler des éléments pour
savoir si elle pouvait ou pas déposer
une plainte si un dépôt de plainte la
justice saisie pourra dire ce qui se
passe je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
problème est politique jusqu à quel
moment dans un contexte où nous voulons
tous que c'est à faire éclater au grand
jour que les victimes soient reconnues
jusqu à quel moment des accusations
accumulé peuvent maintenir un ministre
ou pas en fonction je pense qu'on arrive
à un moment crucial où ce problème se
pose à madame borne à monsieur macro et
jeu j'ai tendance à penser que sans
doute ils seront amenés à agir bientôt
parce que ça ne me paraît pas tenable à
long terme voyez bien commence à
travailler l'opinion voyez bien cette
lycéenne qui interpelle elle n'est pas
politisé 1 elle interpelle spontanément
le président de la république parce que
c'est la chagrine comme femme ça la
chagrine comme citoyenne je pense qu'on
a un vrai problème qui va falloir le
trancher très bientôt
vous êtes vice-président de bien vous
étiez au courant vous aviez entendu
parler avant les révélations
je suis pas un familier de monsieur abad
d'autres qui étaient à l'assemblée ont
semblé dire qu' il était à peine surpris
peut-être pas des accusations de viol
mais en tout cas de comportement
inapproprié
quels qu'ils soient ces comportements
doivent passer au crible de la justice
c'est à elle de nous dire si oui ou non
monsieur abad ecopal personne d'autre ne
peut le dire avant elle en revanche je
dis bien le problème avant d'être
système judiciaire est un problème
politique et ça ne fera qu il soit
tranchée bien vite merci je
l'attends
[Musique]